>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT".
WHEN THE FOUNDERS OF THIS
COUNTRY DESIGNED THE AMERICAN
REPUBLIC SOMETHING WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR, BUT NOT EVERYONE
WAS IMPRESSED BY IT AT THE TIME.
MUCH OF EUROPE SCOFFED AT THE
IDEA NOT JUST BECAUSE THEY WERE
MONARCHISTS, EVEN FREE THINKING
PEOPLE OF THE TIME.
CONTEMPORARY LIBERALS WERE
WORRIED IT WOULDN'T WORK.
THEY DIDN'T THINK IT WOULD.
THEY THOUGHT DEMOCRACY WAS A
WEAK SYSTEM.
AT SOME POINT THEY BELIEVED
UNSCRUPULOUS POLITICIANS WOULD
COME TO POWER, CHANGE THE RULES
IN THEIR FAVOR AND ESTABLISH A
ONE-PARTY STATE.
WHAT BEGAN AS GOVERNMENT BY THE
PEOPLE INEVITABLY WOULD BECOME
TIRE KNEE.
THAT'S WHAT THEY SAID AT THE
TIME.
IT HASN'T HAPPENED.
FOR MORE THAN TWO CENTURIES
THIS COUNTRY RELIED ON OUR
INSTITUTIONS BRILLIANTLY
DESIGNED AND DURABLE
INSTITUTIONS TO SURVIVE AS AN
INTACT DEMOCRACY AND WE HAVE
THROUGH A CIVIL WAR, TWO WORLD
WARS, GREAT DEPRESSION, 9/11
AND MORE.
ALL OF THOSE EVENTS PUT GREAT
STRESS ON OUR SYSTEM.
NONE BROKE IT.
THEN CAME 2016.
DONALD TRUMP'S ELECTION
CONVINCED MANY ON THE LEFT THAT
OUR ASSOCIATIONS NO LONGER WORK.
THEY MUST BE TORCHED AND
REPLACED BY A SYSTEM THAT WILL
PREVENT TRUMP AND ANYONE LIKE
HIM FROM EVER BEING ELECTED
AGAIN.
THAT'S THEIR GOAL.
THEY'RE STARTING WITH THE
JUDICIARY.
AT LEAST FOUR LEADING
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATES HAVE SUGGESTED
PACKING THE SUPREME COURT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
ENLARGING ITS SIZE, ADDING MORE
DEMOCRATIC APPOINTEES, MAKING
IT POLITICAL, A TOOL OF ELECTED
OFFICIALS RATHER THAN AN
INDEPENDENT BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT.
HERE IS ELIZABETH WARREN
EXPLAINING THAT CHANGING THE
COURT IS A FORM OF REVENGE FOR
THE CRIME OF HAVING A
REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT.
>> FIRST THEY STEAL A SUPREME
COURT SEAT, THEY TURN AROUND
AND CHANGE THE RULES ON
FILIBUSTER ON THE SUPREME COURT
SEAT AND SO IT SWINGS BACK
AROUND TO US WHAT WILL WE DO?
MY ANSWER ON THAT IS ALL THE
OPTIONS ARE ON THE TABLE.
>> APPARENTLY CORY BOOKER GOT
THE SAME TALKING POINT.
>> ERIC HOLDER THE FORMER A.G.
IS TALKING ABOUT EXPANDING THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN THE UNITED
STATES SUPREME COURT BEYOND
NINE TO GET MORE PROGRESSIVES.
WHERE ARE YOU ON THAT?
>> I THINK WE NEED TO FIX THE
SUPREME COURT.
THEY STOLE THE SEAT.
I WOULD LIKE TO EXPLORE A LOT
OF OPTIONS AND TERM LIMITS FOR
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES MIGHT BE
ONE THING TO GIVE EVERY
PRESIDENT THE ABILITY TO CHOOSE
THREE.
>> Tucker: KEEP IN MIND THAT
FOR A CENTURY AND A HALF THE
COURT HAS BEEN LIMITED TO NINE
JUSTICES AND HAS WORKED JUST
FINE.
SOME OF THE COURT'S DECISIONS
HAVE BEEN WISE, OTHERS
MISGUIDED AND SOME APPALLING
BUT AMERICANS TRUST THAT THE
COURT IS A REAL INSTITUTION AND
ON THE LEVEL.
THAT TRUST IN THE COURT AND
OTHER INSTITUTIONS KEEPS THIS
COUNTRY STABLE.
WOULD THE PUBLIC HAVE TRUST IN
THE COURT ONCE IT BECOMES AN
ARM OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY?
WHO CARES WHAT THEY THINK?
WHAT PEOPLE FEEL IS NOT A
CONCERN FOR THEM.
THEY WANT THEIR POWER BACK NOW
AND FOREVER AND TO ABOLISH THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE.
THEY'RE CIRCUMVEBTS AWARD THE
PRESIDENCY TO THE WINNER OF THE
NATIONAL POPULAR VOTE.
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATES STRONGLY APPROVE.
>> THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE.
>> THERE IS A LOT TO THAT.
YOU HAD AN ELECTION IN 2016
WHERE THE LOSER GOT 3 MILLION
MORE VOTES THAN THE VICTOR.
THERE IS A LOT OF WISDOM IN
THAT.
>> WE SHOULD HAVE NATIONAL
VOTING AND THAT MEANS GET RID
OF THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE AND
EVERYBODY --
[APPLAUSE]
>> Tucker: IN FACT, THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE HASN'T
FAVORED ONE PARTY OR ANOTHER.
IN 2012 IT FAVORED THE
DEMOCRATS.
IF IT WAS TIED IN THE POPULAR
VOTE BARACK OBAMA WOULD HAVE
WON.
THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE KEEPS THE
COUNTRY FROM BECOMING A COLONY
OF CHICAGO, NEW YORK AND
CALIFORNIA.
A UNION OF EQUAL STATES, NOT A
COLLECTION OF PROVINCES THAT
REVOLVE AROUND A FEW POWERFUL
CITIES.
IT DISCOURAGES THE RISE OF
FACTIONAL PARTIES.
THE BEST ARGUMENT FOR KEEPING
ELECTORAL COLLEGE IS SIMPLE FOR
230 YEARS IT HAS WORKED BETTER
THAN ANY OTHER COUNTRY'S
SYSTEMS IN HISTORY.
BUT BECAUSE IT DIDN'T HELP THE
LEFT WHEN A PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION TWO YEARS AGO THEY
WANT IT GONE FOREVER.
ALONG WITH IT ANY RESTRICTIONS
AT ALL ON WHO CAN VOTE.
VIOLENT FELONS, ILLEGAL ALIENS
AND EVEN CHILDREN.
WHATEVER IT TAKES.
>> I MYSELF HAVE ALWAYS BEEN
FOR LOWERING THE VOTING AGE TO
16.
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
TO CAPTURE KIDS WHEN THEY'RE IN
HIGH SCHOOL AND INTERESTED IN
ALL OF THIS.
WHEN THEY'RE LEARNING ABOUT
GOVERNMENT TO BE ABLE TO VOTE.
>> Tucker: THE SUPREME COURT
AND ELECTORAL COLLEGE
RESTRICTED TO CITIZENS, BURN IT
ALL DONE.
WHAT ELSE STANDS IN THE WAY OF
THE LEFT'S QUEST FOR POWER?
HOW ABOUT THE SENATE.
LEFT WING SAYING SENATE SHOULD
BE ABOLISHED.
THE FIRST AND SECOND AMENDMENT,
THEY HATE THOSE.
SPEED BUMPS ON THE WAY TO TOTAL
CONTROL.
RELICS OF TIME.
SUPREME COURT COULD GET RID OF
THEM AND MAYBE THEY WILL.
KEEP IN MIND.